je ne travaillais pas ce jour là je
l'information dès le lendemain par un
élève
oui qui vous a dit quoi cela dit c'est
une manille clairement débuts dans un
court alors ce n'est pas du tout le lieu
ni le moment à vous savez madame qu'un
professeur s'est fait taper voilà j'ai
coupé koji sa nasse ça va rien à voir là
en cours tu es sur ta copine et je
pensais que j'ai pas pris l'ampleur de
la chose à ce moment là est ce
effectivement on entre en salle des
professeurs que j'ai eu écho de la faire
effectivement comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure il ya dix ans ça n'aurait pas
pu arriver
et encore moi alors la violence en
elle-même elle est à l'inacceptable
mais ce qui choque le plus c'est ce qui
a beaucoup choqué les enseignants c'est
le fait que aucun élève ne soit
intervenu en fait pour interrompre sa tu
des des clash entre guillemets avec les
les élèves on en a souvent mais moi ça
fait dix ans que j'enseigne la tourelle
il ya toujours un camarade qui vient
raisonnée l'élève un peu un peu insolent
où l'élève qui commence à avrillé à
perdre son sang froid
il ya toujours un élève qui vient
s'interposer pour nous protéger nous
mais également pour protéger pardon sont
sans son camarade parce que le fait est
qu'il a dit là était encore jusqu'au
conseil de discipline c'était prévisible
et qu'il a donc été exclu et excluant
que voilà comme on leur a dit puis on a
fait beaucoup de communication avec les
élèves
si vous aviez été des vrais potes entre
guillemets vous aurez pris vous vous
auriez pris part dans votre camarade
pour l'empêcher d'aller jusque là en
fait deux tués vous disiez choqué oui
bien sûr vous est expliqué avec les
élèves est ce que vous leur avez dit que
vous qu'est ce que vous leur avez dit
après ça ce que vous avez fait c'était
compliqué un petit un petit speech en
classe pour l'ouverture
voilà qui est ainsi passé pour qu'on
vous n'avez pas réagi il est donc
impossible était impossible de reprendre
les cours dans c'est de faire comme si
rien ne s'était passé pardon donc oui on
a pris nos élèves de chaque professeur
principal a été parlé à la classe à
vannes au classement naples est par là
nos classes pardon est effectivement à
ce moment là on a décidé de laisser
parler je crois que nos élèves ont
besoin
qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit les élèves
escobar qui ont dit regretter qu'ils se
dépasser et regretté d'une pomme bien
dans un langage c était vous cesse été
condamnés par beaucoup d'élèves
il est condamné parce qu'il n'aurait pas
dû aller jusque là
oui mais en même temps c'est le
professeur qui a commencé c'est lui qui
a donné le premier coup de poing j'ai
envie dire peu importe j'ai même pas
voulu rentrer dans ce débat là
est ce que cette violence est
condamnable oui elle l'est est ce que
vous le comprenez oui on le comprend
parce que toute chose sinon ont eu peur
ensuite servi et finiper maintenant non
pas moi non ce que est ce que tu es des
professeurs vous dites va peut-être nous
être de votre lycée se disent
aujourd'hui je vais y aller mollo je
vais voilà je vais essayer de ne pas
rentrer en conflit mois en conflit avec
les élèves je pense qu'il ne faut pas
entrer effectivement en conflit avec les
élèves je pense alors moi je suis pas un
avis aussi tranché que vous je mettrai
pas tout sur le dos des parents
nous on a un soutien incommensurable des
parents d'accord ils sont derrière nous
on a même parfois des parents qui
viennent nous dire n'hésitez pas à
frapper mon fils si vous manque de
respect
d'accord c'est rigolo c'est là on voit
les chocs le chat sur sur elle mais il
faut boire mais est ce que est ce que
vous les avez vu d'ailleurs les parents
de ce garçon alors pas moi mais est-ce
qu'ils ont été convoqués par alors été
convoqué parce que je sais qu'il ya
derrière il ya sami qui est professeur
et électrotechnique au lycée de sartène
il est professeur principal de celui qui
a agressé le professeur donc de la
classe et est ce que ça me les a
rencontrés çà me kane en privé qu'est ce
qu'on peut donner un micro à sa mission
pelé mercier y en avait un alors ça y
est vous avez vous avez vu les parents
les ont alors ils font
[Applaudissements]
c'est le seul gars et vaut bien qu'on
reconnaît son visage mais pas savoir
c'est vraiment d'accord je veux bien
qu'on me colle mais la voix non ça ne
s'est jamais jamais la mer voilà je ne
veux pas alors sa maîtrise et de poésie
alors effectivement donc je suis
professeur principal de l'élève qui a
qui malheureusement a mené cette
situation alors il faut savoir que tout
de suite après ce qui s'est passé
il m'a contacté les led l'élève m'a
contacté par téléphone il n'était pas du
tout en colère il était vraiment calme
les regretter énormément ce qu'il venait
de faire ça déjà ça les regarde pas
réaliser ce qui s'est passé et encore
moins l'ampleur que ça allait prendre
voilà donc définitivement les parents
tout de suite on réagit le papa dans
l'établissement il était dépité il en a
pleuré et malheureusement aille donc
c'est assez compliqué à gérer
on a les lèvres on a le col de moi je
vais vous dire sa 1000e le sentiment que
j'ai aussi c'est bien sûr il a il a fait
une erreur mais aussi je pense qu'il a
été pas pousser mais il s'est senti
pousser des ailes avec leur d'élèves qui
étaient autour et qui voit là qu'il
chauffait un police justement dès le
lendemain de cette altercation j'ai donc
j'ai pris mes élèves en charge
forcément je devais faire atelier parce
que je suis professeur
d'électrotechnique
mais c'était impossible pour moi de
faire court après ce qui s'était passé
donc j'ai décidé de discuter avec alors
c'est vrai que dans le groupe y en avait
qui certains qui disait que le prof
n'aurais pas dû réagir comme sarah etc
etc
mais après en fait en discutant en
expliquant les choses en recontextualise
en tout ça quand ils ont compris qu'ils
avaient leur part de responsabilité
d'accord et donc et après donc ils ont
pris conscience bien sûr à payzac pris
conscience elles ont au début j'étais
très en colère et ils ont limite menacé
en disant que si l'élève est exclu du
lycée bien le propos s'ils devaient
avoir une sanction etc
mais après en leur expliquant tout ça
ils ont ils ont très bien compris ils
ont très bien compris
après je pour réagir ce qui est ce qui
est choquant dans cette vidéo c'est
effectivement le fait que les camarades
de classe n'ont pas n'ont pas réels sont
pas intervenus
la violence bien sûr mais ce qui me
choque moi en tant qu'enseignant c'est
qu'ils aient personne aucun adulte dans
le couloir à ce moment là pour stopper
pour bourbon pour me donc la faire en
sorte que ça se produise même temps que
ça s'est passé vous êtes en sous
effectif donc mais on est bien évident
et bien évidemment on sait que c'est la
faute de l'éducation nationale turque a
été infligée aux jeunes alors le jeune
il a eu la sanction quelle est la
sanction puisque on n'a pas entendu
karine mathiot micro la sanction elle
était toute façon il était clair la
sanction moi j'avais déjà dit aux élèves
que ça va le mener un conseil de
discipline et que c'est inacceptable
donc il a été il a été exclu du lycée il
a été exclu du lycée plus après il ya
une plainte derrière donc il a été aussi
condamné par la justice il a été
condamné
oui oui la vieille ville est déjà une
peine 14 ans il a eu huit mois huit mois
de prison avec quatre mois dans quatre
mois d'abord aménageable encore après ce
qui est bien aussi c'est qu'on est dans
un système comme éducatif
l'élève n'a pas été laissé tomber malgré
tout ça on a beaucoup travaillé que le
proviseur avec tous les supérieurs pour
leur place et donc malgré la violence de
ce qui s'est passé
enfin moi moi en tant qu'enseignant je
peux pas m'arrêter uniquement ça parce
que c'est pas exceptionnel
ou est-ce que c est ce qu il ya quand
même des comportements de violence voire
des insultes
les sont fréquents dit les choses jamais
jeter des choses franchement je suis pas
là pour effectivement on ressent de plus
en plus de difficultés à exercer notre
métier ça je pense qu'aucun enseignant
qui dira le contraire
maintenant ce qui nous gêne nous moi ça
fait dix ans que je suis dans le lycée
de lacq plus de 10 ans tuée dans le
lycée de la tourelle je vois la
dégradation ça y est né il ya un moment
dans 2010-2011 croire il me semble on a
eu un documentaire qui a été fait sur le
lycée de la tourelle notamment tf1 et
france culture qui étaient venus qui ce
qui qui qui était venu parce que on
avait des indicateurs de réussite au
dessus de la moyenne
dans l'académie oui l'autre au dessus de
la moyenne attendue donc ça s'est
dégradé à s'est dégradé à partir du mot
là on a commencé à supprimer les moyens
donc on espère qu'on est encore là c'est
qu'il ya un manque de moyens ce que vous
dites depuis alors alors juste moi je
devrais revenir deux petits tourner sur
le professeur comment comment il va
aujourd'hui il est il à il a repris le
professeur est en convalescence
d'accord il ya des vacances scolaires
actuellement donc lui il a une envie
c'est de ces aussi de revenir c'est de
revenir il est moralement il est il et
comment il est il est si gère plutôt
bien on va dire accord plutôt bien c'est
sportif c'est un ancien élève du lycée
de la tourelle d'ailleurs d'accord et
lui mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qui lie le
professeur aujourd'hui il pense qu'il a
des torts ou pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé
s'il a des torts et on a toujours des
choses on a toujours en aurons une fois
qu'on voit des images comme ça on se dit
toujours qu'on aurait géré différemment
forcément mais maintenant voilà une fois
je ne faut pas inverser les
responsabilités
mais karim aujourd'hui il ya perte il ya
personne qui représente les élèves
autour de la table voilà je vous dis
puisque personne ne les représente donc
forcément voilà on et doit on a le droit
derrière on a droit
non bien sûr c'est inacceptable mais
c'est pas parce qu'on est professeur
qu'on peut taper tout donc là il ya eu
un excès mais je voulais savoir est-ce
que déjà le professeur est ce que c'est
un professeur qui avait mais aucun
problème avant ben non pas spécialement
des altercations comme tu pas sûr